wintershall ya lleva un par de años
fuera de las canchas y a pesar de que
ubisoft tuvo sus altos y sus bajos con
la saga su último juego resultó ser
excelente y en lo personal un juego que
he jugado demasiadas veces con el pasar
del tiempo aol o splinter cell black
list un juego en donde recuperaríamos
algunas de las cosas que hicieron
esprinters en una saga tan buena sigilo
equipo gafas de visión nocturna con tres
enormes luces verdes visibles a 30
metros de distancia ya saben cosas de
espías al igual que con splinter cell
conviction a pesar de ser juegos
excelentes tienen muy pocos datos
curiosos y es muy difícil encontrar
información del juego aún así usando mi
colosal cerebro logré reunir un par de
datos sobre el juego que espero te
resulten interesantes acompáñame a
descubrir 10 curiosidades secretos y
detalles y splinter cell black list
la historia de vlad les toma lugar tan
solo seis meses después de los eventos
de splinter cell conviction lo que nos
demuestra que el pobre de sham no puede
descansar nunca splinter cell black les
es hasta ahora el juego más grande en
toda la saga teniendo un montón de
misiones armas y trajes personalizables
muchísimo equipo misiones en línea y
cooperativo y mucho más incluso también
se crea una aplicación para iphone
llamada spider bot para promocionar la
salida del juego en una imagen de el
juego podremos ver en una de las
pantallas del paladín un mensaje que
dice nueva operación in the fire dios y
lo que pudo haber sido un de ls
cancelado que tenían planeado para el
juego pero debido a la poca aceptación
que tuvo black les prefirieron
eliminarlo michael ireland side es
generado la voz a sam fisher en
absolutamente todos los juegos en su
versión en inglés siendo alguien muy
conocido por los fans de esprinters él
pero para esprinters el black list
lamentablemente tuvieron que dejar a
iron and side por fuera del proyecto y
contratar a alguien más para darle la
voz a sam esto pasó ya que para darle
una animación más fluida y gráficos más
pulidos a black list usaron la
tecnología de motion capture
que involucra un constante movimiento y
esfuerzo y iron side debido a su edad no
puede esforzarse tanto esta fue una de
las razones del fracaso del juego por
los fans estaban tan apegados a michael
que cuando lo reemplazaron y cambiaron
la voz de sam prefirieron no comprar el
juego que me cambies la voz de sanz pues
no te compro el juego [ __ ] existe una
novela llamada black list after mad que
narra una nueva misión de sam y su
equipo después de los hechos de el final
del juego
este juego contó con una edición de
coleccionista limitada que contenía una
novela gráfica del juego y un avión a
control remoto idéntico al que vemos en
el juego algo bastante extraño que vemos
durante el juego es que en la campaña
cuando jugamos con sanz todo normal pero
cuando jugamos con bricks de repente el
juego cambia de perspectiva a primera
persona esto supuestamente fue hecho de
esta manera para demostrar que bridge a
pesar de ser un gran soldado es menos
experimentado que sam y no está tan
acostumbrado al sigilo prefiriendo hacer
algo más directo en sus misiones
de la misma manera que vimos en el vídeo
de convección en este juego también
existe un pequeño secreto durante los
créditos finales si nos comemos la mitad
de los créditos nuevamente podemos
escuchar una conversación acerca de la
vez que alguien trató de venderle un
elefante a sham
d
desde hace 16 años se ha estado
trabajando en una película de splinter
cell pero desde entonces poco a poco
todo se ha ido a la [ __ ] pues año tras
año el proyecto era aplazado y cambiado
en directores constantemente pues nadie
quería trabajar en la película en 2012
un pequeño rayo de esperanza creció pues
tom hardy fue anunciado para interpretar
a un joven sam fisher y luego el mismo
tom hardy a través de sus redes sociales
anunció que la película comenzaría a
filmarse en 2016 y sería estrenada en
algún punto del 2017 pero
desafortunadamente esto fue lo último
que se ha sabido de la película pues aún
en 2021 que yo sepa no se ha estrenado
tal vez la película fue tan buena con el
sigilo que pasó desapercibida por todos
el caso es que a pesar de todo lo que
tom hardy dijo de la película todo
parece indicar que fue cancelada hace
mucho tiempo aún así un soft no pierde
la fe de ver la película algún día pues
según ha comentado al momento de crear
el modelo para sam fisher en esprinters
el black list se inspiraron en varios
actores para que así al momento de
seleccionar a un actor para que
interprete a sam sea más fácil esperemos
que algún día podamos ver a sam fisher
rompiendo madres en la gran pantalla
algo bien sabido a estas alturas es que
ubisoft le encanta we soft pues en casi
todos sus juegos podremos encontrar
referencias a sus propios juegos como
assassin's creed o what stoxx estas
referencias han llevado muchos jugadores
a teorizar que todos los juegos de
ubisoft comparten un mismo universo así
como marvel pero con bugs perdón dice es
que es un multiverso y farcry nido no
hizo más que reafirmar esta teoría pues
en este juego podemos encontrar un
interés referenciando a sprint tercero
para los que no lo saben farcry newton
toma lugar en un mundo postapocalíptico
luego de una guerra nuclear
en una de las misiones secundarias del
juego si exploramos un poco podemos
encontrarnos con los restos destruidos
del paladín el avión que vemos en
sprinter cell black list si nos
adentramos aquí y eliminamos a todos los
enemigos podremos interactuar con una
computadora que nos mostrará una
pantalla idéntica a la del juego lo que
nos demuestra que sam y su equipo
estaban tratando de evitar la guerra
justo antes de que las bombas derribarán
su avión luego de hacer esto subiendo
unas escaleras podemos encontrar el
característico traje de sam fisher que
podemos ponerle a nuestro personaje pero
esto no es todo ya que a medida que
exploremos el lugar podremos ir
encontrando notas dejadas por el mismo
sham en donde nos cuenta qué fue lo que
pasó cuando la guerra estalló y cómo
luego de buscar a su hija y ponerla a
salvo tuvo que adaptarse a este nuevo
mundo destruido este creo que es el
mejor y esta ley que hay en faringdon y
no me malentiendan me encanta el interés
pero uso cabrón sería un poco mejor que
en vez de un interés hiciera es un juego
nuevo digo no
lo dije al principio y lo vuelvo a decir
esprinters el black list es excelente sé
que a muchas personas no les gustó mucho
porque ahora está muy dirigido a la
acción y aunque decía es cierto que no
está a la altura de los grandes como que
yo story es muy entretenido es una
verdadera pena el hecho de que desde
hace más de 8 años no hemos visto nada
más relacionado a la saga y mucho más
triste considerando el hecho de que
desde el 2013 ubisoft ha hecho seis
juegos de assassin's creed 3 the watch
dogs y 5 the far cry pero ni de asomo
uno de sprinters el pulso no seas cabrón
pero hay que mantener las esperanzas de
que algún día se anuncie un nuevo
splinter cell ya sea la continuación o
un reinicio de la saga o sea lo que sea
por mi bien en fin cuéntenme que les
parecieron estos datos y también si
black list les parece al igual que a mí
un buen juego o sólo uno más del montón
hasta la próxima
[Música]